360 exclusive inside
the fighting in Ukraine
from a perspective
that's never been shown before.
The view from inside a Ukrainian combat
helicopter flying at treetop level
and sometimes below the tree line
under constant threat from ground
fire and fighters above.
Flying
these choppers
is one of the most dangerous jobs
in this war.
And with Russia
beginning a new offensive,
it could soon get even riskier.
CNN Sam Kiley has the story.
The target is
Russian troops
a hard bank left
and a dove
and flares to distract
Heat-Seeking missiles.
A pair of Ukrainian helicopters
on an assault against Russian forces
close to parliament.
Russian aircraft
are raging around the border.
It's on the front line.
You should be careful
when you go watch a flight
from very low altitude and very low speed
to prevent
to prevent our recognition
below trenches.
And east
Ukrainian villages smashed by war
just
back from the sortie.
This forward base is secret,
as low profile as possible.
The eight helicopters are refueled
and rearmed.
They expect to fly at least three sorties
a day.
When you took off this morning,
were you frightened by
Well, because the Russians
want to kill you.
So they don't have any other choice
than to fight the Russians.
If you frightened, should stay at home.
That's not an option here.
This Soviet
era helicopter is about 30 years old.
The threat against it is extreme.
And as a result of that,
we're having to fly
quite literally below
the height of trees,
climbing and chipping with every piece of
woodland that we pass.
Built as transport aircraft.
They're most vulnerable
when they climb to shoot their rockets,
diving for cover to 20 feet above
the ground is also perilous.
A change in sound
indicates a tree strike
by the helicopter's blades
Back at base,
the blades are swapped quickly.
Ukraine doesn't have aircraft to spare.
This
no pilots, sir.
He skippers the chopper
that hit the trees
in year of routine.
He tells me in December,
a very close friend of mine died.
A lot of people
I knew
friends have already died, unfortunately.
It's very painful and I'm very upset
and I cannot move on.
We're supposed to.
He went on.
We need new attack helicopters, new jets.
Unfortunately, our equipment is old
and its range is very small,
and it's inaccurate.
A year into fighting Russia's invasion,
Ukraine is still asking for more advanced
helicopters and jets.
So far, the response from her
allies has been sorry, but no.
And so they fight on here with what
they've got
Kylie joins us now from eastern Ukraine.
That's incredible.
What was it like in that helicopter?
I mean,
the idea that you're flying below
the tree
line,
that the rotor of the helicopter
actually hit a tree?
I mean, it's extraordinary
the risk that these pilots are taking
It is extraordinary risk.
It's a real sad David and Goliath.
If we needed one of those comparisons
in Ukraine, that would be it.
These are ancient helicopters,
that sort of
Soviet equivalent of a Black Hawk,
but a very old and ancient
Blackhawk transport helicopter fitted
with these rocket pods
and sent into battle of fearful
of fighter
jets, of surface
to air missiles, of ground fire
I mean, they
and when we were on that aircraft,
I could have almost leant out the window
and touched the stubble
of the trees,
of the fields of passing below me.
So it really is extremely high risk.
They have taken pretty heavy
casualties, particularly
at the beginning of the war,
before they could organize themselves.
The other thing
I think is important to note here,
by fluke entirely by fluke,
a lot of these veteran pilots
have been flying
recently in the last 15,
20 years on a peacekeeping missions
with the United Nations in Africa.
So they've got a lot of hours.
They've got a lot of hours
in areas of conflict,
like the Democratic Republic
of the Congo and Sierra Leone.
Liberia, Mozambique and elsewhere.
And as a consequence of that,
they're pretty,
very, very highly skilled.
And they're all paired
with much younger pilots.
But one of the younger pilots
I spoke to who has been flying in
just a few years
this year alone, Anderson,
he counted to 100 combat sorties
and then stop bothering Anderson.
Incredible.
Sam Kiley, thank you for that report.
Really extraordinary.
CNN military
analyst and retired Army
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling
joins us now.
General Hurley,
I mean, are those helicopters
even designed for fear that
they are?
Anderson, those are my 17 helicopters.
I think I just picked it up on the film
as Sam was doing his report.
And what what they're flying is
what's called nap of the Earth.
All combat aircraft do that.
They try and stay as low as possible
to avoid any kind of radar signatures.
And there is that up and down
nap of the earth
under undulating terrain.
But they are firing rocket pods
and rocket
pods are not precision weapons.
They're are somewhat
the artillery of the air.
So it's difficult
to really get a target strike with that
unless you're
literally pointing at the target.
And you could see
the helicopter
was flying over the terrain.
And as they just fired their rockets,
they're really aiming toward an area
for an area fire versus a precise target.
So what would more advanced
aircraft, advanced helicopters or,
you know,
helicopter gunships or aircraft?
What would that allow
Ukrainian forces to do that they can't?
Well, in some cases,
certainly they
advanced Western style aircraft.
Sam mentioned the Black Hawk.
I kind of chafed a little bit
when you said they're Asian ancient
because they are not ancient.
They're actually pretty new
in the Army's imagery.
But it will allow them more transport.
It would give them guns on the side,
the same kind of rocket pods
where I think
the pilots you're talking about
are more the attack helicopters.
Like Apaches or even Cobras.
Those are extremely expensive,
very technologically advanced,
takes a whole lot of training
and a whole lot of maintenance.
But they fire precision weapons
from the aircraft
and they can be tank killers
from literally
almost up to 12 kilometers away.
But the training on that,
how long does that take?
It's immense.
You know,
there's been talk a lot about the F-16s.
You would probably have
to put as much time
in an Apache helicopters
you would for an F-16.
And there's,
you know,
a lot of language saying
we need to give them the F-16.
You're in
ad who's the spokesman for the Ukrainian
Air Force,
just said last week
that it would take
Ukrainian pilots
a couple of weeks
to just learn how to fly fighter jets.
But about six months to really master
how to fight the aircraft.
That's about the same
for an Apache helicopter
because they are
so technologically advanced.
They have heads up displays
on their helmets themselves.
Takes two pilots
and it would just really take a very long
training time
besides being extremely expensive.
General Hurtling, I appreciate it.
Thank you.